let's get you some breaking news coming
out of India now Parliament has
disqualified opposition politician Rahul
Gandhi as mp on Thursday a court found
Gandhi guilty of defamation and
sentenced him to two years in prison the
52 year old is a Scion of the nehru
Gandhi political Dynasty and he was
convicted for comments he made about
prime minister Narendra modi's surname
at an election rally in 2019. let's go
straight to public who is live in New
Delhi so this news just out in the last
10 minutes or so
so tell us a bit more what impact will
this disqualification have
look political parties in India have
been raising the issue of what they say
is a threat a threat to democracy in
India they have been protesting this for
a while and a lot of these issues have
come to a head today as you said just a
few minutes ago we got the news that
Rahul Gandhi has been disqualified as
Member of Parliament a day after he was
sentenced for two years for making
comments uh four years ago at an
election rally and that case was filed
against him by a member of prime
minister Narendra modi's party janta
party in the state of Gujarat which is
the state that Modi was chief minister
for for over a decade narahul Gandhi is
the de facto face of India's opposition
so this is you know big news here in
addition to that he's also someone who
has led a lot of the criticism against
prime minister Narendra Modi he has
accused Modi of crony capitalism them
and uh sort of favoring certain business
houses for lucrative contracts he's also
led the criticism on uh on minority
rights the issue of minority rights in
India now as of now as far as the court
case is concerned uh Gandhi is out on
bail he has about 30 days and his team
will be appealing that decision in a
higher court right now his party that is
the congress party has been protesting
over here actually on these grounds a
few a few minutes ago some of those MPS
have been detained by the police they're
also asking for an appointment with the
president saying that the bharti janta
party the governing party has been
targeting opposition leaders by misusing
a central investigative agencies
exactly I mean the timing of the of all
this seems very interesting I mean as
you say some of India's main opposition
parties say that the governing BJP is
misusing government agencies to Target
opponents what is going to come out of
those accusations
well as of now 14 political opposition
parties have banded together and filed a
case in India's Supreme Court with those
very allegations that Central agencies
are being misused so that case is going
on but in addition to that the
opposition parties have sort of been
protesting inside the parliament as well
today there were protests they have been
doing that for a while now outside the
parliament on the streets and this has
been the sentiment for a while now and
it's not just Rahul Gandhi's party you
know as we speak at least two other
members of office opposition parties are
under investigation for alleged
corruption now those leaders have denied
wrongdoing but they also say that
investigative agencies haven't actually
found anything and this is an
intimidation tactic now all of this
plays out in a larger political context
and that is that next year around this
time India is heading for general
elections and so opposition parties
believe that these are intimidation
tactics to sort of make sure that the
BJP has an upper hand in those elections
this criticism is also not coming from
opposition parties it's important to say
that even human rights groups have been
saying for a while now that since prime
minister Narendra Modi came to power in
2014 the space for descent in India has
been shrinking it's not just political
leaders but also activists and movie
stars who they say have been targeted
I'm criticizing Modi okay thank you so
much for that update pavni metal there
for us live in New Delhi
lots more still to come ahead on Al
Jazeera